[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle semaine d'information
locale bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
pour cette nouvelle édition du journal
sur tv 60,18 voici les titres de ce
lundi 13 juillet il est reconduit à la
tête de l'agglomération président de
saint quentin en yvelines depuis 2010
est jean michel fourgous a été réélu
samedi lors de la séance d'installation
de la collectivité
une séance au vélodrome national pour
garantir la distanciation physique entre
les élus communautaires
après la crise sanitaire des vacances à
prenantes pour les élèves elles ont pour
but de renforcer les apprentissages en
ajoutant des activités culturelles ou
sportives
reportage à poissy où les jeunes
alternent entre soutien scolaire et
pratique du football
et puis un été de septième art à la
commanderie pour la deuxième année
consécutive le site installé à elancourt
propose des séances de cinéma en plein
air une animation qui a débuté jeudi
dernier qui va se poursuivre jusqu'à la
fin août
après les conseils d'installation des
mairies c'était au tour de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines de désigner ses représentants
la séance se déroulait à samedi à
dernier le conseil communautaire s'est
tenue au vélodrome nationale à montigny
le bretonneux pas de grande surprise
puisque jean michel fourgous et garde la
présidence de la collectivité
je déclare donc reçu fourgous président
de la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin encouragement un nouveau
mandat de six ans pour le maire les
républicains d'elancourt pour ce conseil
d'agglomération de la mandature 2020
2026 jean michel fourgous était seul
candidat à sa succession
une présidence qu'il place sous le signe
de l'emploi et des entreprises pour
répondre à la crise sociale
notre enjeu prioritaire sera l'emploi
bien sûr et la sauvegarde de notre tissu
économique et du niveau de vie
le 12 commun c'est notre devoir d'élus
locaux d'aider les jeunes français à
entrer aussi sur le marché du travail
ça va être un moment difficile ne devons
pas avoir une génération sacrifiée une
élection aussi pour quinze
vice-présidents comme en 2017 jean
michel fourgous a choisi de donner des
délégations aux quatre maires de gauche
françois morton édile de guyancourt et
nouvel élu communautaire
hérite de la politique de la ville de la
santé et des solidarités je pense que
c'est important la politique de la ville
je la connais bien je la pratique au
niveau de mu en cours depuis maintenant
presque la totalité du mandat puisque
j'ai été élu à la politique de la ville
et la santé est évidemment un enjeu
primordial
après la période que nous venons de
ville vivre et les solidarités c'est
l'adn de la ville de guyancourt nouveaux
conseillers aussi lorrain merker qui est
en charge de l'urbanisme et de
l'aménagement du territoire
il devient aussi le premier vice
président de l'agglomération
ce que je veux retenir surtout moi ce
matin c'est la cohésion qui a eu au
niveau de tous les élus un grand sens
des responsabilités de chacun et je
trouve ça très encourageant est très
enthousiasmant pour les six années à
venir
et le fait de voir tous les élus quels
que soient leurs bords qui souhaitent
travailler ensemble de cette manière
quand je pense qu'on va pouvoir bien
bien travailler pendant ses six années
l'environnement et la transition
écologique thèmes forts de la dernière
campagne des municipales sont confiés à
la mère de plaisir joséphine coleman
bergès l'environnement en tant que tel
fait partie de quelque chose de
transversale on va le retrouver
absolument partout j'ai déjà évoqué avec
certains vices présidents cette
nécessité de travailler ensemble que ce
soit sur l'habitat que soi même dans les
commerces dans le développement
économique
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus inscrire un
développement économique sans tenir
compte de l'environnement jean michel
fourgous a prévenu les conseillers
communautaires ce mandat sera celui du
rassemblement face aux difficultés
sanitaires et économiques
parmi les gros projets à la charge de
l'agglomération l'accueil de plusieurs
épreuves sportives lors des jeux
olympiques de 2024 et jean michel
fourgous réélu donc pour un nouveau
mandat lui qui avait été élu pour la
première fois en 2017 succédant à michel
laugier devenu sénateur
le président de saint quentin en
yvelines que nous avons interrogés
samedi en sortie de séance patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les moyens
techniques et je suis donc avec jean
michel fourgous président réélu à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonjour vous
avez donc été réélu lors de cette séance
d'installation du conseil communautaire
ce samedi 11 juillet dans quel état
d'esprit abordez-vous c'est ce nouveau
mandat ces six prochaines années
et bien déjà une
dans un message avec une ambiance un
état d'esprit je dirais de rassemblement
de tout
de tous les élus on sent quand même 1 1
même une évolution voyez c'est toute une
histoire cette agglomération qui monte
en puissance
bon aujourd'hui est clair qu'il ya un
état d'esprit beaucoup plus fort
beaucoup plus uni
mais encore perfectible et ça c'est
rassurant surtout pour affronter demain
des éléments qui sont nouveaux qui sont
inédits après une crise sanitaire
économique qui arrive sociale
effectivement c'est rassurant c'est un
gros bateau on l'a dit saint quentin en
yvelines
on sait qu'on va prendre un bain
entre force 5 force vite et peut-être au
dessus il faudra le pied marin ils ont
montré
on se connaît on commence à se connaître
travail de plus en plus ensemble tous
ensemble
c'est rassurant d'avoir un équipage
quelle expérience et puis quelques
semaines état d'esprit pour tous les
administrés de cinquante et un équipage
feriez c'était votre souhait en 2017
lors de votre élection d'ouvrir au les
vice-présidents sommaire aussi des élus
de les maires de gauche pardon là
c'était important de renouveler ce
travail ce travail commun vous savez au
delà d'être de gauche à droite moi je
fais ce qui marche ça a marché sur le
mandat précédent nous ouvrir à écouter
j'ai même ouvert un peu plus parce que
les délégations queneau
jamie l'opposition sont encore plus
importantes que l'anr fois donc voilà on
veut
je crois que c'est comme ça se construit
aussi la confiance et la qualité du
travail
donc voilà je suis très confiant tout
cas et les messages de très sympathique
qui vont aussi adressé en dehors de
celui des changes par sms maintenant
cessé mais tout ça c'est bon pour saint
quentin c'est bon pour pour les deux
sens des 35000 personnes qui vivent à
saint quentin alors que ceux qui
travaillent c'est très bon signe parce
que il va falloir être réactif
voilà décider vite comme ils l'ont fait
d'ailleurs pendant la crise du coc vide
ils ont été assez exceptionnelle bon
voilà force de se connaître vous savez
ans estime on désamorce les images les
caricatures qui peuvent être faites
entre les adversaires politiques dont je
trouve voilà je suis très heureux de
prendre quelques jours là parce que je
veux j'ai ramé depuis cinquante deux
mois puis je remercie aussi nos amis du
conseil régional et
décret c' est du département monsieur
liés qu'on qui jouent aujourd'hui un
rôle très important pour consolider
saint quentin comme commun des pépites
comme le dit monsieur bédié une des
pépites de falla pépite femmes ont peu
importe une des pépites wade du
département à la pour pour faire monter
pour être l'un des modèles en france de
2,2 de la recherche et du développement
de l'intelligence de j'irai de tous tous
les grands enjeux et puis de cette
université paris saclay qui monte en
puissance ça faisait un moment qu'on le
disait mais là là depuis quelques jours
le placement en mathématiques est quand
même une indiscipline des plis fier
devant les plus scientifiques numéro un
mondial vous m'auriez dit ça je ne vous
aurais pas cru
parce qu'on avait du mal à passer dans
le top 20 de shanghai tout d'un coup sûr
là les mathématiques on se retrouve
premier devant 4000 l'université dans le
monde attendait ses épices et c'est
toute la culture numérique que vous avez
derrière donc c'est quand même lui qui
depuis sans changer le monde aujourd'hui
c'est certainement j'ai eu beaucoup de
bonnes nouvelles si en ce moment à part
ce qu évident
mais
ça donne confiance ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui
on n'est pas candidat d'opposition
côté c'est un signe aussi plus
beaucoup de bonnes choses mais se sont
exprimés
par les petits problèmes
le niveau des prêts une technique avec
ses nouvelles
c'est système de vote mais non non non
on est tous très contents et on s'est
tous félicités
opposition et majorité c'est bon signe
du sein les grands dossiers forcément
sur sur ces six prochaines années on a
envie de penser tout de suite aux jo
c'est bientôt les géo l'agglomération se
prépare attend avec impatience ses jeux
olympiques c'est déjà parti c'est qu'il
ya eu ce petit
c'est une concurrence avec chamounix
mais on a gagné a priori entre
chamanique non c'est bien quatre sites à
monsieur déjà commencé essayer déjà des
soucis je vous rappelle qu'elle gèle
travaux qui sont menés ici effectivement
c'est en ce vélodrome qui accueillera
les épreuves de cyclisme sur piste
il ya eu beaucoup de travaux sur une île
loisir puisque c'est au coeur de deux
des trois sites olympiques colline bmx
et puis vélodrome mais il ya des études
qui travaillent et qui sont faites en ce
moment pour préparer le plus beau l
événement au monde
il faut quand même le dire on est
d'abord très flatté que saint quentin on
est en dessous nous attribue 4 sites
olympiques
dire qu'on a montré avec la ryder cup
qu'on savait montre augmenter d
événement de dimension mondiale
voilà mais tout ça et puis vous aimez
lire on a quand même les plus belles
boîtes ce résultat son université pour
les étudiants mais vous avez tout le
mode et l'étudiant qui monte en
puissance
le numérique a beaucoup aidés
à saint quentin on a été cité en exemple
comme ils disent à gauche sinon mieux
tenus dans cette crise
des supports éducatifs parce
qu'effectivement il y avait
même si encore perfectible mais bien sûr
qu'il ya eu un a suivi de scolarité qui
a été bien sûr nettement meilleur grâce
à cette culture numérique donc il faut
là il faut continuer à être poussé bien
entendu culture numérique et aussi des
enjeux on a envie de penser au
développement durable aux transports ça
ça va aussi animé il ya cette ligne 18
qui est toujours en préparation et qui
est prévue en 2030 je crois à 50 ans
divine ça ça se poursuit ses projets
également la ligne 18 les voix douce
avec les vélos fortement demandés
surtout avec 300 vélos toute façon et
jeux olympiques en quête de nouvelles
pistes cyclables a simplement effectué
cyclab les bus électriques enfin je
serais bien passé a beaucoup depuis la
voiture autonome qui variés parce que y
en a une partie fabriqué à saint quentin
donc voilà donc on va certainement avoir
les bénéfices beaucoup plus vite
comédien de transport merci jean michel
fourgous je le rappelle vous avez été
réélu ce matin ce samedi 11 juillet
président de saint quentin en yvelines
un nouveau mandat de six ans à la tête
de l'agglomération lui et conseiller
communautaire de saint quentin en
yvelines élu d'opposition dans la
commune de trappes othman nzru est
devenu le premier vice président de la
région ile de france est désignée lors
de la séance plénière vendredi dernier
jusque là président du groupe de la
majorité de droite il remplace et jérôme
chartier qui a démissionné en décembre
dernier pour rappel othman nasri a
également annoncé la semaine dernière sa
candidature à l'élection législative
partielle dans la 12e circonscription
des yvelines tout comme le maire de bois
d'arcy philippe benassaya autres
collectivités dans le nord- yvelines
grand paris seine et oise qui a un
nouveau président raphaël cognait mer et
l'air de mantes-la-jolie a été élu à la
tête de la communauté urbaine vendredi
avec 91% des suffrages il succède ainsi
à philippe tautou et gps hors groupe 73
commune structurée en pôles urbains
villes intermédiaires et communes
rurales et grand paris seine et oise et
tant de rôles base à conflans sainte
honorine en passant notamment par mantes
la jolie
depuis le 6 juillet ce sont les vacances
scolaires les vacances d'été et comme
chaque année le rectorat de versailles
propose l'école ouverte c'est un
dispositif qui est renforcée cette année
avec les vacances et apprenantes plus de
25000 jeunes sont concernés dont la
moitié en éducation prioritaire
vendredi dernier une quinzaine d'élèves
visitait le potager du roi dans la cité
royale en compagnie de charline avenel
rectrice de l'académie de versailles les
propos recueillis par mélanie poker en
double
clairement on fait plus que doubler les
ce qu'on a l'habitude de faire parce que
les dispositifs d'école ouverte c'est
quelque chose dont on a l'habitude on
n'est pas parti de rien et d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que ça marche bien mais on
les a doublées et on les a doublées
grâce au volontariat des chefs
d'établissement grâce au volontariat des
enseignants qui ont pensé qu' il était
souhaitable pour leurs élèves de pouvoir
proposer un programme de renforcement
mais en même temps qu'ils sont un
programme très enrichissant
personnellement et à poissy les vacances
d'apprenants de ce fonds balle au pied
au cours de soutien scolaire sont
ajoutés également des entraînements de
football assurée par l'académie fondée
par le champion du monde 98 bernard
diomède et depuis le 6 juillet une
centaine d'élèves du cm2 à la troisième
est accueillie au sein du collège des
grands-champs le reportage de michael
ennemis devront allier le football et
les cours pendant les vacances scolaires
le collège les grands champs de poissy
propos ce dispositif depuis le 6 juillet
dernier près d'une centaine d'élèves
participent à ce programme pris en
charge par l'éducation nationale et la
ville dans le cadre des vacances
apprenantes cette particularité c'est
qu'on accueille des élèves des trois
collèges de poids sic desgrandchamps
donc notre là où on est actuellement le
collège le corbusier le collège jaurès
et même quelques cm2 qui vont rentrer en
6e l'année prochaine sont également
accueillis pour faire un gros plat
homogène unis par la passion du foot là
c'est la première chose et qu'ils sont
prêts à travailler tous les matins et
vraiment ça renouveler au programme
chaque jour des cours de deux heures le
matin avec au planning des mathématiques
et du français
les élèves se dirigent ensuite vers des
ateliers de football une recette qui
fonctionne
je trouve que c'est bien surtout que on
travaille
on fait on fait du travail après on va
faire du sport surtout le sport que
j'aime bien le foot je trouve que c'est
bien parce que on travaille parce qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup travaillé pendant que
coronavirus et en même temps après le
travail on partage et me ensemble
moi je préfère le foot mais c'est comme
travailler aussi
ce stage de football éducatif est
organisée en partenariat avec l'académie
du champion du monde 1998 bernard
diomède un parrain prestigieux qui a
permis de médiatiser ce dispositif
je pense que le foot a légèrement
orientés l'inscription des élèves
la plupart sont des footballeurs ils
sont la plupart licenciés ou en club il
ya très peu de d'élèves qui ne l'ont
jamais de foot au pardon
même s'il y en a sur une très bonne
formule après une demi-heure de football
premier verdict c'est un peu compliqué
parce que ça faisait longtemps que je
n'avais pas tu es donc c'est un peu
compliqué mais sinon tout va bien bon
franchement c'est bon aussi
on sait chauffer un peu et ça fait du
bien puisque avec le coin n'avions pas
toutes les équipes ont repris donc à
voir cette grande première à poissy se
terminera ce mercredi 15 juillet pour
clôturer la session bernard diomède
devrait de nouveau être présent ce
mercredi matin pour donner quelques
conseils sportifs et sur l'éducation
dans l'actualité également la
célébration du 14 juillet une fête
nationale fortement chamboulé demain en
raison de la crise sanitaire et les feux
d'artifice et autres animations été
annulées dans les communes du
département à la place des hommages aux
soignants et personnels des hôpitaux
notamment pour ceux de l'hôpital
andré-mignot au chesnay rocancourt
mercredi la patrouille de france doit
passer au dessus de l'établissement aux
alentours de 16h25 et les pilotes
devraient même libéré les célèbres
fumigènes tricolore aucun rassemblement
n'était prévu mais n'hésitez pas tout de
même à lever la tête vers le ciel rendez
vous ce mercredi 15 juillet aux
alentours de 16h25
il a ouvert le 17 juin le musée de la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines a
repris ses visites en douceur
l'exposition temporaire est prolongée
jusqu'à l'année prochaine et les équipes
ont concocté un programme estival plutôt
tourné vers l'extérieur le reportage de
mélanie poquet de manon
aldo épidémie oblige les gestes
barrières sont de rigueur au musée de la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines
mais l'établissement reçoit à nouveau
des visiteurs depuis quinze jours sur le
mois de juin ça a été très très calme
les gens sont revenus doucement un peu
pour voir aussi ce qui avait été mis en
place et puis je pense qu'il avait
d'autres priorités ce qui est bien ce
qui est bien normal
et puis là on voit le héros ils
reviennent on les voit revenir ce mois
de juillet on sent que c'est il ya un
vrai retour à la normale on voit que les
gestes barrières sont bien respectées
dans musée et puis voilà on est sur une
fréquentation qui nous permet
d'assouplir un petit peu donc on va
avoir une jauge limitée à 15 personnes
dans les espaces du musée et on a
supprimé le sens de circulation mais
maintenu par contre l'obligation du port
du masque et la distanciation physx une
période de pause forcée mise à profit
par les équipes programmation repenser
création de visites virtuelles et d'un
été très culturel l'histoire de saint
quentin en yvelines se transmet cet été
en visites extérieures et également des
visites à vélo qui sont des formules qui
sont très chouette l'été et faut dire
que ça quentin en yvelines offre une
quantité de sentiers de chemin qu'on
peut utiliser un vélo et qui permet
vraiment de re découvrir ce territoire
autrement et souvent les gens sont sans
vraiment surpris de ce dont on peut
parcourir l'ensemble du territoire
la rentrée aussi sera animé la nuit des
musées décalé au 14 novembre
et puis du 9 juillet au 27 août la
commanderie de saint quentin en yvelines
propose du cinéma en plein air l'entrée
gratuite la séance se déroule tous les
jeudis soir dans le parc de la coulée
verte à elancourt pour la première la
semaine dernière c'était itil
extraterrestre de steven spielberg qui
était proposé en projection marie des
nappes ishino et mathilde et demi au
parc de la coulée verte les spectateurs
s'installent dans l'herbe
munis de chaises de plaids ou encore de
coussins pour cette première séance le
public est au rendez vous plus de 840 4
entrées ont été comptabilisées au
programme le film
iti un classique pour commencer la
deuxième saison du cinéma en plein air à
la commanderie on est venu en famille
avec les enfants
on a trouvé ça sympathique comme idée
c'est la première fois qu'on vient et
donc on est venu avec les enfants tout
en famille pour voir un film qu'on a vu
quand on était petit voilà nez avec nos
cousines et notre tata pour regarder un
film en plein air oui c'est la première
fois mais on prend l'air en même temps
de regarder les cinémas c'est agréable
on a voulu aller voir le film
richie et l'année dernière on y est allé
et on a comme ça nous a plu maintenant
on va essayer d'y aller chaque année
pour faire patienter le public
l'orc est l'harmonie de saint quentin en
yvelines s'est joint à l'événement pour
faire profiter d'un interlude musical
[Musique]
des fous trucks sont aussi présents pour
ceux qui n'avaient pas prévu de pique
nique
les films sont on a essayé de les
choisir vraiment pour soi familiale ce
soit des comédies des comédies qu'on a
pu voir des films et historique des
adaptations littéraires mais qui reste
assez facile d'accès pour que ce soit
main un public lambda qui puisse venir
au cinéma tranquillement la nuit est en
train de tomber il ne manque plus que
l'écran géant qui est gonflé quelques
minutes avant le début du film pour les
prochains rendez vous du cinéma en plein
air les yvelinois pourront découvrir ou
redécouvrir le grand bain charlie et la
chocolaterie ou encore little miss
sunshine
infos pratiques avant de vous laisser le
service de collecte des déchets est
annulé pour la journée de demain mardi à
saint quentin en yvelines les jours de
rattrapage dans votre commune sont à
consulter sur le site de l'agglomération
voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
merci de l'avoir suivi très belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]